I had grown up around a lot of teachers
my mom was a teacher my sister became a
teacher and after college so many my
friends went into teaching and so many
of my friends that were teaching in city
schools were having trouble with their
students that were keeping up at grade
level on in the reading and writing in
particular they would talk to me about
this and say you know what we really
need is just more people more bodies
more one-on-one attention more sort of
hours more expertise from people that
have a skills in English and could work
out with these students one-on-one so
when I moved back to San Francisco and
we went to this building and the idea
was to put McSweeney's quarterly that we
published twice or three times a year
and a few other magazines we're going to
move it into an office and we were going
to actually share space with a tutoring
center so we thought where have all
these writers and editors and everybody
sort of a writing community coming into
the office every day anyway
why don't we just open up the front of
the building to students to come in
there after after school get extra help
on their written homework so you have
basically no border between these two
communities SEP 4 the landlord said well
the space is zoned for retail you have
to come up with something you've got to
sell something you can't just you know
have a tutoring center so we thought
haha while we were renovating this place
somebody said you know really kind of
looks like the hull of a ship and
somebody else said well you should sell
pirate supplies so this is the pirate
supply store and then right behind it we
set up this space which was the tutoring
center so right there is the tutoring
center and then behind the curtain was
the McSweeney's offices where all of us
would be working on the magazine and
book editing and things like that and
what we were trying to offer was every
day with one-on-one attention the goal
is to have a one-to-one ratio with every
one of these students and so you know
it's been proven that 35 to 40 hours a
year with one-on-one attention a student
can get one grade level higher so we
started off with about 12 volunteers and
then we had about 50 and then a couple
hundred and we now have 1400 volunteers
on our roster it became this sort of
weird happy accident so all the people I
used to know in Brooklyn they said well
why don't we have a place like that here
a lot of them had been you know former
educators or would-be educators so they
combined with a lot of local designers
local writers and they just took the
idea independently and they did their
own thing they didn't want to sell
pirate supplies they didn't think that
that was going to work there so knowing
the crime-fighting community in New York
they opened the Brooklyn superhero
Supply Company and this is La the Echo
Park time travel Mart whenever you are
we're all ready then these are spaces
that are only affiliated with us doing
the same thing word street in Pittsfield
Massachusetts thanks bud
Cincinnati you speak San Francisco
California which inspired us studio st.
Louis and st. Louis Austin bat cave in
Austin and fighting words in Dublin
Ireland to be opened in April we hope to
usher in a new era of participation in
our public schools so we created a
website it's called once upon a school
this site will document every story
every project that comes out of this
conference and around the world so you
go to the website you see a bunch of
ideas you can be inspired by and then
you add your own projects once you get
started we hope that you will take the
lead in partnering your innovative
spirit and expertise with that of
innovative educators in your community
always let the teachers lead the way
they will tell you how to be useful
there's a million ways you can walk up
to your local school and consult with
the teachers they'll always tell you how
to help so this is the Ted wish I wish
that you you personally in every
creative individual and organization
that you know will find a way to
directly engage with the public school
in your area and that you will then tell
the story of how you got involved so
that within a year we have a thousand
examples thousand examples of
transformative partnerships the schools
need you the teachers need you students
and parents need you they need your
actual person your physical personhood
and your open minds and open ears and
boundless compassion sitting next to
them listening and nodding and asking
questions for hours at a time some of
these kids just don't plain know how
good they are how smart and how much
they have to say you can tell them you
can shine that light on them one human
interaction at a time so we hope you'll
join us thank you so much
[Applause]